do you guys think body count matters
yes yes 100 is this for both genders
yeah uh for women let's say for women
and then for do women than men so okay
oh not for men no no matters for yeah
God women yes
men not so much okay
no neither okay I don't think it I think
it only matters
how it's put out there
because somebody a woman can have a high
body cat nobody knows about it she
carries us or even men will know about
it and she carries herself different
mamble tree are different
but you can have somebody with a high
body care not even as high as that
woman's body care and it's all out there
for everyone to see it's all over the
internet then it matters because you
must know women that got high high body
Cuts you still respect them because the
way they carry themselves